it's a complex effort to rescue Mark
Dickey trapped deep inside this cave in
the southern Turkish province of Merson
the 40 year old joined an international
caving Expedition late last month
but he began vomiting and suffered
stomach bleeding while descending
it has been over a week since he became
trapped more than a thousand meters down
this is a vertical a cave with a lot of
water it's for a Celsius degrees the
temperature inside the cave we have to
use a vertical technique rope techniques
and I had to have a lot of narrow
passage
doctors say his condition has improved
but he's required several blood
transfusions inside the cave leaving him
unable to climb out on his own
morka cave beneath the Taurus Mountains
is over 12 000 meters deep making it
turkey's third deepest cave with base
camps set up in stages it will take
hours for Rescuers to reach Dickey's
position
more than 150 Rescuers from turkey and
other countries are involved in the
difficult operation
we have received reports from inside the
cave that his condition is getting
better that he is in stable condition
190 Personnel are part of the rescue
efforts ranging from eight different
countries
Rescuers are setting up rope lines
inside the cave to remove the injured
caver on a stretcher
to bring him to the surface you will
have to stop and rest frequently at
camps set up along the way as Rescuers
pull his stretcher through the narrow
passages but the rescue is so
complicated that Mark Dickey is not
expected to make it back to the surface
for nearly another week
imranola Khan Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera